las gráficas de la función lineal fx
igual a mx b y la función exponencial
ahora déjenme cambio de color de x igual
aa por r a la x donde r es mayor que 0
pasan por los siguientes par de puntos
estos 2 - 19 y 11
ambas gráficas se dan a continuación y
son estas dos de aquí esté aquí es gd x
que habíamos puesto con color rojo que
de xy si te das cuenta es una función
exponencial esta de aquí
mientras que la recta es fx que habíamos
puesto con este color
fx y es una recta que está decreciendo
también la función exponencial es una
función exponencial que está decreciendo
por lo tanto si me dicen que eres mayor
que cero bueno hasta podríamos asegurar
que r está entre 0 y 1 las funciones
exponenciales cuya r cuya base está
entre 0 y 1 son funciones exponenciales
que decrecen perfecto ahora lo que nos
piden es explícitamente cuáles fx y
cuáles
así que lo primero que se me ocurre es
que fx la podemos obtener fijándonos en
estos dos puntos es decir fx fx igual a
m x + b es decir que cuando nosotros
tenemos una recta que pasa por dos
puntos bueno lo primero que hacemos es
sacar su pendiente entonces como sacamos
la pendiente la pendiente sabemos que es
el cambio en la comparación del cambio
en x el cambio en la comparación de
cambio en x y bueno como tenemos esto
pues hay que fijarnos en cuanto
cambiamos en jeff en esta recta a
comparación de cuanto cambiamos en x y
si te das cuenta en y empezamos en este
punto este punto si lo tenemos y vamos a
bajar vamos a bajar todo esto todo esto
todo esto hasta llegar a este punto de
aquí es decir que todo esto es muy
cambio en todo este este declive es mi
cambio en james y por lo tanto nosotros
podemos decir que es la diferencia de
estos dos puntos recuerdas eso es lo
mismo que
9 - el otro punto de 91 ok y ahora si
nos fijamos en el cambio en x pues
cambiamos de este valor que tengo aquí
hasta este valor que tengo aquí todo
esto es lo que estamos cambiando
nosotros en x en esta recta por lo tanto
va a ser desde menos uno desde menos 1
hasta 1 - 1 - 1 ok y de lujo y cuantos
esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo antes
de ponerlo con este color que 9 menos 1
es 8 entre menos uno menos uno lo cual
es menos dos menos dos o dicho de otra
manera ya podemos construir la pendiente
es lo mismo que 8 entre menos 2 lo cual
es menos 4 del lujo ya tenemos la
pendiente muy pendiente vale menos 4 y
eso quiere decir que por cada uno que yo
me mueva en x y aquí hay que tener
cuidado con la escala vamos a ponerlo
con este color por cada uno que yo me
mueva en x es decir aquí me estoy
moviendo 1 en x tengo que bajar 4 en jr
así que cuidando la escala aquí baja
1 2 3 4 es decir llegó justo a este
punto de aquí ok por cada uno que yo
caminen x igual para acá voy a bajar 4
en jeff y llegó justo este punto de aquí
de lujo ahora ya tenemos la pendiente
podemos decir que fx efe de it is es lo
mismo que m pero la pendiente ya la
obtuvimos vale menos 4
déjeme ponerlo con ese mismo color menos
4 que multiplica a x que multiplicará x
+ b pero ahora lo que nos hace falta es
la be y para obtener la vez que te
parece si utilizamos alguno de estos
puntos se me ocurre tomar este de aquí
si nos fijamos en f1 quienes efe de uno
bueno por la definición esto es lo mismo
que menos 4 es decir la pendiente menos
4 por x pero x en este caso vale uno por
uno más b
ok pero esto nosotros sabemos que es uno
estamos en el punto 1,1 y por lo tanto f
no me está diciendo que es uno entonces
esto es lo mismo que uno ahora si nos
fijamos solamente en esta parte de aquí
podemos obtener el valor de b
dicho de otra manera y déjame cambiar de
color menos cuatro por uno es menos
cuatro menos cuatro más b esto es igual
a uno o podemos decir que ven es lo
mismo que 4155 ya tengo el valor de b b
vale 5 y bueno era casi seguro que
valiera 5 porque estábamos parados en
este punto de kim este punto pertenece
la recta pero no sabíamos si era 55.1 o
4.99 pero ahora estamos seguros de que
es 5 ya obtuvimos que la intersección
con el eje layes es b igual a 5 y por lo
tanto ya tengo toda la información para
poder concluir cuál es mi función
fx mi función fx fx es igual a m a la
pendiente o pero nosotros sabemos que la
pendiente vale menos 4 menos 4 por x x
x por equis ok podemos variar x + ven
más bien pero nosotros sabemos que en b
vale 5 y ya está aquí toda mi función
fd x que es una función lineal ya la
tengo aquí y date cuenta que ya tengo
todo lo necesario para conocer bien a fx
fx ya solamente depende de x y cumple
esta expresión que tengo aquí ahora
vamos a intentar sacar algo parecido
para gdx para mi función exponencial que
decae y para sacar a gtx y la voy a
apuntar justo aquí gx x es igual a am
por r elevado a la x ok donde eres mayor
que 0 para obtener gdx que te parece si
trabajamos otra vez con estos dos puntos
el primer punto el primer punto es este
que tengo aquí que me dice que cuando x
vale menos 1 gdx vale 9 porque este
punto pasa tanto en la línea como en la
función exponencial y lo voy a utilizar
dice que cuando g
- 1 cuando x vale menos 1 esto es lo
mismo que a por er elevado al menos 1
que por cierto esto es lo mismo que y
utilizando la información del punto me
dice que cuando x vale menos 17 x vale 9
esto es lo mismo que 9 y de aquí ya
tengo una ecuación a por r elevado a la
menos uno es igual a 9 o bueno esto lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
esta parte de aquí se puede escribir
como a porque r elevado a la menos uno
es lo mismo que dividir entre r es lo
mismo que 9 o bueno de aquí podemos
decir aquí podemos decir que a es igual
a 9 r a 9 r porque voy a multiplicar
todo por r y está r se va a cancelar y
bueno aquí ya tengo una ecuación a es
igual a 9 r y ahora qué te parece si
buscamos otra ecuación parecida para
poder de aquí obtener el valor de r y el
valor de a y bueno para eso voy a
utilizar el segundo punto este otro
punto que tengo aquí y este otro punto
que tengo aquí que es justo este de aquí
me dice que cuando x
17 x vale 1 es decir kg de 1g de 1 es
exactamente lo mismo que a por r elevado
a la primera potencia pero bueno elevado
la primera potencia a por r y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que quede uno que
vale uno justo esto es lo que me está
diciendo este punto importantísimo a por
r es igual a uno y aquí ya tengo otra
ecuación a por r es igual a 1 a por r es
igual a 1
ya tengo esta ecuación de acá arriba ya
tengo esta cuestión de trabajo habrá
forma de obtener aa rr y me parece que
sí así que para esto déjenme bajar un
poco la pantalla o que bajemos un poco
la pantalla y voy a trabajar con estas
dos igualdades es más que te parece si
utilizamos esta información de que es
igual a 9 r para sustituir la aquí abajo
voy a sustituir a justo aquí es decir me
va a quedar que a por r pero a vale 9 r
9 r que multiplica a su vez a r que
multiplica a su vez a r
esto es lo mismo que uno es lo que me
dice la ecuación de abajo y bueno la
veré por r es nueve veces re cuadrada
esto es lo mismo que uno o dicho de otra
manera es re cuadrada r cuadrada que es
lo mismo que uno entre nueve ok ahora
vamos a recordar el hecho de que sea
mayor que cero justo eso es lo que me
pide el problema que r dónde r es mayor
que cero por lo tanto ahora voy a
obtener el valor de f
si saco de esta igualdad raíz cuadrada
es decir que r es lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada de un noveno que es un tercio
un tercio me voy a quedar con la raíz
positiva porque me dicen que r es mayor
que cero ok
r es un tercio y entonces ya que obtuve
r qué te parece si ahora obtengo yo sé
que a es igual a nueve por r lo voy a
poner aquí a es igual a nueve por r pero
ya sé cuánto va a leer errebal un tercio
por lo tanto a es igual a nueve por un
tercio ok
por un tercio está húmeda nueve tercios
o tres y vale tres y ya tengo el valor
de a abel 3 y el valor de r los cuales
los necesitaba para obtener esta función
exponencial gtx ahora ya puedo saber
cuánto vale gdx puedo decir que gx cdx
es igual a a pero a vale 3 ok por r pero
r vale un tercio positivo por un tercio
elevado a la equis elevado a la equis y
de lujo y también ya sé cuánto vale gdx
gdx es igual a 3 por un tercio elevado a
la equis es una función exponencial y
bueno esta función exponencial la
obtuvimos sacando cuánto vale r y cuánto
vale a de estas dos ecuaciones que tengo
aquí y bueno ha llegado el momento de
escribir las respuestas entonces vamos a
bajar la pantalla y justo aquí vamos a
escribir que fx fx es menos 4 x5 color
menos 4
+ 5 ok y gtx gx es y voy a cambiar de
color es lo mismo que un tercio o era 3
por un tercio por un tercio esto elevado
a la equis de lujo ahora si tenemos las
respuestas